ils ont tellement perdu commenter les
causes perdues
aussi même plus comment tu as eu à l'âge
de trois ans que souley devenir comédien
c'est vrai comment ça c'est pas aussi je
pense pas qu'à ce moment là je savais
que je voulais devenir comédienne tant
que ça mais j'ai vu des enfants la télé
je les ai vus agir à travers mon écran
puis j'ai eu envie d'être puis à 10 ans
j'ai eu une option pour un conte pour
tous de rock demers pour un film en
anglais qui j'ai eu le rôle fait que
c'était mon premier rôle en effet là où
il y avait vraiment quelque chose à
jouer
depuis les dernières années l'hérault se
sont enchaînées pour toi dans le film
bon cop bad cop 2 mais aussi à la
télévision qu'on pense à vrak tv dans le
chalet dans les pays d'en haut
ton frère va dire ton secret à ton
charme quelle route le plus marqué quels
secrets
j'avoue que un personnage comme donald
dans les pays d'en haut c'est un
personnage qui est très très fort très
complet c'est vraiment un privilège pour
une comédienne de l'aborder parce que
c'est un personnage qui très approfondie
parce que comme c'est une série à
travers trois saisons je peux passer
partie de la gamme d'émotions you peu
d'argent parce qu'il fait crédit aux
pauvres cela dit le personnage que je
fais dans le chalet qui s'appelle sarah
geismar sisters fois c'est vraiment un
grand plaisir aussi de l'interpréter
parce que ses proches de moi c'est un
autre défi sport parce que ses proches
de moi que c'est plus facile à faire
mais je n'oublie jamais alors le rendre
dans une peña jeune j'avais seulement
j'ai demandé au site
c'était la première fois je faisais pas
la fille de la soeur de j'étais vraiment
un personnage à part entière on ça n'est
pas mon contexte familial j'avais comme
un personnage a créé de a à z
donc pour moi ça c'était une aventure
vraiment intéressante je t'aime
autre défi que doit relever c'est dans
la web série féminin féminin way a
diffusé sur tou.tv où tu joues le ronde
de la conjointe de macha limonchik est
ce que tu aimes tu es encore
non non c'est pas une question d'amour
c'est une question d'être réaliste série
qu'elle est faite par des fils font
partie de la communauté lesbienne
donc j'ai pas l'impression de j'ai pas
de syndrome de l'imposteur
j'ai l'impression de jouer une fille
fils et une fille puis ça adonne que
j'ai jamais abordé le personnage comme
étant deux filles qui étaient lesbiennes
témoin la courbe de mon personnage c'est
l'attirance d'âge à travers un couple ça
change rien fait partie d'une septième
génération celle de 4,9 ac de pierre-luc
punk excuses de cosmos entourant ces
jeunes acteurs agresso ce que tu le vois
comme ça moi j'ai évolué dans le milieu
de la télévision
donc je me suis fait des amis sur des
projets télé c'est mais mes amis les
plus proches sont les amis que j'ai dans
la série le chalet ses meilleurs amis à
l'extérieur hors écran c'est avec eux
que je saute quand j'ai des super nanny
contrat que c'est tout petit peu notre
génération c'est vrai que on se rend
compte dans dans des soirées pendant
débarque dans l'esprit pis ça se
croisent puis ça finit par heure ça
finit juste par le défunt donc dans le
fond ce qu'on voit à la télévision
parfois c'est laisser la vraie vie dans
sa soupe hier le sphinx qui croisait à
gauche et à droite lors de ce pub ben j
ai juste d envoyer un texto juste avant
de vous parler parce qu'on sait qu'on va
faire d'abord en deux jours de la boxe
oui en fait de la boxe ensemble car les
frank et moi un autre talent ce parce
que je sais aussi que ce fait de la
rénovation talent je sais pas oui je
fais de la région et les deux défauts là
il ya un lien en d2 maintenant oui tu
vois environ 300 milles abonnés sur
instagram points et plus de 70 milles
sur facebook que je consacrais et a pas
de secret c'est super plate comme
réponse mais honnêtement c'est juste
arrivé
moi je pense que
le moment ou instagram est en plein
essor stade il ya quelques années c'est
le moment où j'étais à la fois dans la
série le chalet à la fois dans la part
du cinquième jeu joué dans les pays d'en
haut
y'avait yamaska qui était diffusé
j'allais rejoindre plusieurs publics ces
gens là ont décidé de me suivre les
réseaux sociaux puis moi c'est pas forcé
j'imagine que les gens l'ont senti
qu'ils ont eu envie de me suivre
ça adonne qu'elles sont rendus beaucoup
mais j'ai un intérêt pour l'esthétisme
pour la mode
je pense que ça rejoint plein de gens et
en même temps certaines personnes
probablement sont juste intéressés par
ma vie parce que c'est ma carrière c'est
juste arrivé entrevue sur le plateau de
tournage du prochain film de xavier
dolan
ouais comment ça s'est passé pour toi
sur le plateau de tournage vous aviez
c'est un ami c'est vraiment par amitié
qui m'en fasse un truc troll est un clin
d'oeil dans le film qui sera même plus
dans le film parce qu'en fait j'ai fait
une annonce publique et xavier comme
quoi le personnage de du scotch ashton
n'est plus dans le montage final je
faisais l'assistante de disques chastain
une expérience enrichissante
parce que de travailler avec lui et avec
juste ce que ça a changé ma vision de
mon propre travail
c'est fascinant et travaille vraiment
autrement le temps qu'on a pris par sem
le fait d'avoir de la musique quand on
répète les conseils que je dise comment
donner ça a été une expérience que je
vais porter longtemps parce que tu as
été déçus de voir que ton rôle avait été
supprimée dieu pas du tout parce que moi
l'expérience de tournage allait vécu
puis c'est un risque à prendre comme
comédien dès que tu as un petit rôle
dans quelque chose ça se peut que tu te
retrouves pour montage final ça fait
partie du travail puis honnêtement à
partir du moment où j'avais passé deux
ans sur le plateau je te contentes
vraiment merci beaucoup